let's talk about the apocalypse guys oh
good gas prices on the road to five
dollars nationwide very soon um that's
the news congratulations everyone i hope
your vote for joe biden was worth it
it's at 4.71 cents per gallon in
california it's over eight dollars
so uh
you know apocalypse win
apocalypse now no that's a movie yeah i
didn't mean to say that out loud
it was too tempting not to say yeah
you kind of you kind of look like me if
we go through like one more pandemic
yeah yes and then shave i feel you i
feel like we both speared by we could
like interchange our looks right now
yeah party very nicely uh apocalypse i
don't know what does apocalypse mean
does that mean the end of the world we
talked about the people who want
revolution and all that stuff and we can
talk about the political implications of
what would drive actual conflict but
it's going to be this
when people can't afford to go to work
anymore when the cost of getting to work
is more than the work produces people
stop working of course yeah
remember the toilet paper shortage that
was a people were really scared yeah you
know two weeks toilet paper and that was
weird too because i was like just use
your hand and then wash your hands right
yeah aren't we all doing that
[Laughter]
literally
i suggest it uh
it actually feels better too it's less
dry wait i wanted to add i was joking no
i don't joke around i gotta ask him this
question tim you said a number a long
time ago a certain percentage of
people's income if it goes toward food
that would be the marker of a revolution
what percentage was that oh i don't
remember we were reading something yeah
it depends if you're dating a feminist
or not i mean yeah that's fair yeah
because they eat a lot
because they're like i'm healthy at
every size that's right and then you're
like okay
and then you're giving them the french
so the apocalypse from ancient greek is
a literary genre in which a supernatural
being reveals cosmic mysteries or the
future to a human intermediary
has that already happened is that what
the internet is
have we created like some sort of super
being yes communicating with us and
making people crazy
don't look at it it's like the ark in
indiana jones
if you look at it
you're like
yeah that's what the internet is the
phone is the arc you turn it on you're
like
on your face that's what it really feels
like
so true actually that would be a good
kind do you feel like we're more the
reality is more now the internet than
reality i think we've actually s we've
just crossed the line yeah well it's the
it's the younger generation
yeah so when you know i say this for
people people don't understand that you
don't convince people to join your side
like it happens it does an individual is
convinced of your argument and then
becomes whatever
you know politics you have what really
happens for the most part is young
people have those values and then grow
up with them
rarely are people actually jumping
shipwrecking yeah so
you're saying the reality becoming more
like more the internet it's because
boomers and gen xers who grew up in
reality are slowly aging out right once
they're gone it's all millennials the
internet will be everything right
unless the power goes out i normally
don't all i hardly ever say like we need
some sort of catastrophe to show people
what really matters in life i think it's
from time to time but i don't want to
bring that on people but if the power
went out and people have to
that would be missile yeah that would be
it
they would be like fish out of water
they would just like fall down and go
like i was not like yeah even if they
just stopped tick tock right now
there'd be millions of people in the
street just dancing just like for now
hoping someone sees it it's the weirdest
thing we'd have like meltdown the first
when tick tock first started happening i
remember we were in jersey yeah and i
look out the window and there's some
like little girl in the middle of the
street just doing this weird dancing
and i was like
what's going on and then she saw the
flag
in the middle of the street
and then she walks up to a mailbox and
picks her phone up and i was like oh she
was filming herself and i was like what
is this and then i saw it all over the
place people would be in the malls and
they would just be like standing in the
corner like doing weird and i'm like wow
like listening to hearing songs no one
else can hear it's over yeah it's over
we can't come back from that yo people
are going to plug into elon musk's
neuralink to join the metaverse in two
seconds yeah they're gonna be bagging
elon musk is gonna be like the first
edition of neuralink can be surgically
implanted and we'll do it for free just
come over here and we'll jam the spike
in your neck and they're gonna be like
please heal on me
i want to be in tick-tock
so like live in that reality if we've
got a sort of a cast system set up right
now where you have the really wealthy
people that never think about money
really they never have to even think
about unless they want to make more of
it then you have like the working class
and then you have the abject poor now if
you have the meta versions
where
are they might be lower than the abject
poor it might actually be considered
abject poor they're just like getting
intravenous you know nutrition and
getting their
harvesting their body heat or something
for
but then it's going to create
a class of like workers that hate
reality but are willing to do it because
they don't want to be part of the lower
slave class like the metaverse class
i think it's going to create another you
guys ever watched battlestar galactica
yeah
no you've never seen it it's pretty good
so uh one of the best shows ever totally
so i'll give you the short version
there's a bunch of different colonies on
all these different planets
they make these ai robots the ia robots
go to war with them then eventually the
civilization gets wiped out because you
know the ali the robots advance
themselves and then declare war so now
all that's left is like a fleet of ships
that are traveling
away from the wiped out civilization and
there are ships that refine the
materials they need for fuel and stuff
and the people who work on them have no
choice and they're basically slaves they
work 80 hours they don't get time off
because if they stop working the whole
thing collapses they'll die
but then the captain of course he has to
deal with the conflict of struggling to
survive but he's got the nice whiskey in
his office and you know he's in charge
and that's just like that's the reality
of struggle in the real world this is a
documentary about amazon
so
they actually have episodes where it's
like people are trying not to work
because their lives are miserable on
these mining ships or refining ships and
they're like if you stop working we all
die yeah and then they're like we've got
to rotate other people in because people
can't do this anymore and they're like
if they can't do it they can't do it and
we need the people who can so that's
just that's the reality of existence so
if we ever created like an actual
metaverse civilization then you're gonna
have some people who are the privileged
elites who are in the metaverse and the
poor people shoveling mud and dirt
outside to make the machine run with
their masks on with their masks on so
you could have classes within the
metaverse of rich people in the
metaverse that can control the code and
see the code and everybody else yeah the
zuckerberg class they're gonna walk up
to you ian and you're gonna be like
zuck i don't like what you did he's
gonna go beep beep beep and you're gonna
turn into a giraffe he'll like teleport
in and i'll be like i wanna teleport
he's like if you work your whole life
you might be able to and 40 years go by
me trying and then
no it doesn't happen they'll like
there will be the elite class i mean
it's happening now we don't even it's
not even sci-fi you've got the powerful
elites who can control big tech and
manipulate what you see and hear
to make you think what they want you to
think it already exists you're seeing
this within comedians they're starting
to go all right what was banned on tick
tock this week so what are the things
you have to avoid oh you got to make a
thumbnail like this don't include this
image a friend of mine his tic tac was
just taken down because he had a picture
of a gun wow wow and it's i'm i'm banned
from there every
every other week or permaban from
tic-tac-toe i've never even gotten i
don't even know why but it's starting to
shape uh comedy yeah cancel culture is
shaping comedy and everyone's terrified
so i talked i talked to a guy we might
have in the show and the general idea is
they know they can't win on free speech
grounds
so they're trying to control what young
people see and hear so that
oh yeah let tim cast iral have their
conversations who cares they're in their
30s by the time these 15 year olds are
in their 30s they're going to hate free
speech and they're going to do as
they're told
that's where we're going yeah it's
it's launched already it's not free
speech
if our speech is getting censored by
corporations at will just because of
what the ceo wants to do that's not
that's not freedom they're getting
people to actually cancel themselves
that's kind of how i think of it yeah
it's because i i started to do that i
started to censor myself on stage and
when my with my writing and i'm like oh
i'm actually canceling myself and my
material is getting so boring so people
aren't watching it just do a joke where
you just bleep out the words so keep the
joke but just bleep it
right on
yeah so or on stage so you can be like i
met a guy right he came from this
country a bunch of bleeps you know
that would be a funny joke yeah the
whole thing he's sleeping bleeps you
know these blips this bleep knows what
i'm talking about
he's a little bleepist
you can't say that because you'll get
banned on the internet for hate speech
you could call someone a bleep yeah
or just carry carry a thing that beeps
and so you're talking about
then you can keep all your jokes i think
you're right about self-censorship it's
one of the more dangerous things that
can happen to someone right now because
it's such early stage of like internet
censorship still we have an opportunity
you know we're constantly at crossroads
to fix and make these things better with
free software copy left software yeah
but self-censorship in the meantime is
the road to ruin i mean i i had uh uh
millions of views taken off i did a
fouchy impression and they actually
called it imitate removed for imitation
what what like this is comedy what
you were pretending to be dr fauci yeah
i did just him just talking about you
know like the first shot really just to
loosen up the vein then we do the third
fourth and fifth shot which is to create
a fisa community then seven through ten
or placebos getting us to twelve okay
and all of these are removed and they
say removed for imitation now that's
different than impersonation
impersonating someone is illegal you're
not allowed to i'm not allowed to tell
people i'm tim poole and use tim's
credit card like that's illegal yeah if
i go on social media make a tim account
tim
yeah but
my trumps are taking down so fast like
faster than they'd see pelosi with their
eyebrows she does they won't let you do
trump oh trump was removed last uh uh
two days ago in i think it was 11
minutes from tick tock wow and it's like
it's because they don't want people to
enjoy their ccp they they can't handle
the power of goodness no these trump
impersonations make trump likeable
yeah yeah because he's funny right
whatever you would think of him he's
he's actually really funny
but it's so scary that now the the
guidelines on tick tock are 5 000 pages
long same with instagram they can remove
it for any reason they want and they
have so many reasons now where it could
just be removed because somebody got a
little upset oh yeah removed because ccp
thinks you're going to upturn their
communist dictatorship right it's bite
dance is the company that owns it and
that's basically run through the ccp i
i've never touched the crap i refuse i'm
um
yeah but our choice
tick tock it's trash but it became like
a survival thing for me because my
instagram got shadow band and it's like
take my tick tock blew up and then i
started to tour and then they shut it
down and it's
and people are it's re it's a problem
they want to to control the culture of
young people so that they believe what
they want them to believe and behave the
way they want them to behave and so the
people who run these companies it's a
ccp right they're manipulating us
they're attacking us they're our
adversaries
i hate to say it but it blows my mind
it's it's at some point you got to call
a spade a spade like in 1934 germany i
don't think i would have been happy with
with hitler's rhetoric and i probably
wouldn't have been on on maybe i i
wasn't there i don't know but the the
slaves the uyghurs in in western china
unconscionable i can't deal with it i
own
freaking software that was built by
these people unfortunately
or hardware i should call it but i i
can't stand for it man that's that's
slate we still live if you guys really
care about slavery and racism turn your
eyes on the ccp no they don't
i don't think anybody is just for the
most
do you know what was the biggest
contributor to the end of slavery
it was uh
it was industrialization yes i was i was
reading about it when
humans
did when when
the easiest thing for a person was to
have a slave they would fight to
maintain that slave
but once industrialization began and it
was actually cheaper to maintain a
machine than a person then you lost
economic incentive the reality was
humans were motivated by money and greed
to have slaves i mean that's fairly
obvious right
so once that was once it was cheaper to
have a machine they were just like
you lost the support for it and then
abolitionist sentiment started to grow
it's crazy right
people people people assume it was a
moral thing
where like humans woke up one day and
were like you know i've realized it's
wrong what we're doing no the reality
was they were making more money not
having slaves so no one supported it and
then the fight imagining some guy going
is this bad
right
yeah
on a scale from one to a hundred tony is
this
yeah this this plays with what you were
saying about battlestar galactica too
they have slaves because they have to
literally to survive for the ship to
survive they need people to work 80-hour
weeks in the coal mine that's crazy
i think your civilization would collapse
at that point like in battlestar
galactica when they have these people in
the refining ships or whatever it was
i'd be like no dude people would
probably just lose it
like that
the show is about them adrift basically
with like limited resources it's one
thing to be on a planet where you can
always go off and try and survive on
your own it's another thing just have be
like in a desert with nothing do you
think they'll be able to convince enough
people where it really becomes the
dominant force just whatever the what do
you want to call it woke brain disease
whatever it is
but it really is a brainwashing i i feel
like young people are starting to snap
like they just they're they're sick of
it they're sick of
young people are rebellious right and
they don't have lives anymore no one has
a life no one has a relationship or a
house or a good job
so what isn't it yeah yeah we need more
more relationships more jobs more cool
jobs like using lasers to make graphene
so there's i think these blank slaters
who think they can raise people to be a
certain way are gonna have a rude
awakening when they realize that it's a
little bit of nature and nurture yep and
you can't just remove the nature from
people so these young people who are
like on tick-tock they they crave human
affection and attention and they're not
getting it they're going to snap
and they're going to say the system is
broken i don't want to live this way i
used to think you could get enough for
relationships through internet video
chat and i had a friend tell me like no
i don't think so it was like in 2007 and
i was i was manic about the internet the
power of internet video i was like no i
mean you can meet the most intelligent
people you know video chat with them you
don't need secret service there you can
it's if this is it this is the future
and it's doesn't compare to
this yeah where there's some sort of you
can smell each other there was no unit
oh i do yeah there's a
this is a this is a a fact
humans are happier around nature yes and
so they actually did controls to
determine people's rated levels of
happiness and they found that
people who live in cities are unhappy
because of the city and if you take
people from cities and bring them to
nature their levels of happiness go up
yep i'm dying inside from from being in
new york i mean it really is dangerous
and it's falling apart right now but uh
it's it's taking a toll yeah yeah no i
i'm i'm plotting i'm plotting there is
you know what i see when i walk outside
chickens yeah you know they say when i
walk outside
bach
it's fantastic andrew i think andrew
huberman the uh neuroscientist are you
guys familiar with his work huberman
labs he's brilliant brilliant i dabble
in his work but not too far he's been on
rogan a couple times at least once and
he has uncovered or has been really
pushing looking into the horizon every
day for like 15 minutes because the
amount i don't know if it's about your
peripheral vision but it's the unfocused
long-distance view is supposedly one of
the greatest things you can do for your
mental health according to andrew i
deferred the scientist on that one in
montana that's where that we shot tara
on the prairie and we just we were in
between two mountain ranges in the
middle of a prairie
and i just stared out into the which
ranges who do you play in the movie uh i
play a guy his name is long hair believe
it or not
uh yeah long hair and uh yeah he's he's
uh he was in the civil war and uh not on
the not on the correct side oh depending
who you ask and me um nick cearcy yes um
uh
nick yeah nick circy um heath friedman
an actor who actually passed away right
after the film oh wow and uh daniel day
lewis's son in his first ever film gabe
and the four of us yeah we're just
seeking revenge and and going after
cowboy cerrone who's not home
but gina's home his wife and then we uh
we spend two hours fighting her oh wow
yeah that sounds fun nice when's that
out a little knocked out june 14th
on the daily wire daily wire cranking
out the hits
yeah they're they're man i think they
are they're actually going to be a
contender for netflix in a few years yep
i agree i think netflix thinks that too
they're done i mean they're basically
like hey we can't make these did you see
what they said we can't make these
crappy movies like the irishman anymore
i don't know if they didn't use the word
crappy but they're like these pat we
can't use these like ego projects
anymore we're like wow rich people get
to just
ob1
it was like
there was an article i saw and it said
star wars has a uh like a plot problem
it's like it's all done it's all written
we know exactly
that's the plan all they're doing with
these shows is like let's just reuse the
same characters oh and i'm i'm just like
if
they tried doing the sequel movies and
they were just total trash
the the the industry is decaying just
totally yeah
well i think it's a lot of the woke
ideology thing they're they're just
picking people based on what they look
like instead of their talent or their
audition they're just putting them you
know in front of the chessboard and
daily wire if they keep it up uh i think
they're gonna clean up they're not doing
that they're taking that script they
just had three female leads in a row and
they said it's not because we wanted to
have like it was a decision those were
the best scripts that came across our
table and they read thousands yeah and
if they really keep it up i mean they
cast our film i they saw me on instagram
and gave me an audition
they didn't do a social background check
which they do now on netflix and all
these shows wow they just picked the
best auditions
and i the film's incredible i think
their their movies are going to be
people are going to want to see them i
will give a shout out to guardians of
the galaxy because
guardians of the galaxy one and two i
think are some they're some of my
favorite movies just because they they
use the old soundtrack
so you have this movie and the way they
use the old music and brought it all
back is just one of the coolest things
but it also is indicative of like a
decaying culture where we have
like
i think because of guardians of the
galaxy all these old songs from the 70s
reach top charting positions and i'm
like it's cool because the music was
better in a lot of ways back then in my
opinion even though i wasn't around for
it yeah you know some of it was
i mean crosby stills nash and young four
dudes singing four-part vocal harmony
for the recording all together they went
nuts well young did neil young
neil young is a pretty special man hey
you i want we're gonna go to super chat
soon but i wanted to ask you like you
said you were basically bankrupt in like
abject poverty then you now are making
six figures because of peterson but like
what was that transition like for you
well jordan gave me a hundred thousand
dollars oh that's more
simple
i just have to do an impression of him
like on every podcast i think for young
kids that have been pursuing the
entertainment industry i was in
hollywood for like a decade too it's
scary what would you advise
god it's the wild west right now i mean
look i i mean i actually started losing
agents and managers they'd say
outright we can't help you because
you're white they'd email me they tell
me on the phone
the last manager that scouted me said we
aren't taking white men
it's a it's a real problem i'm not
saying some white men aren't gonna get
in and and uh and by the way this hurts
everybody this isn't even about white or
black or brown or anything because if
you give someone a job who isn't
qualified in hollywood they're gonna get
eaten alive because it is a brutal
brutal business
but what i did this is just my own story
i just said screw it i started making my
own stuff writing my own scripts
funded all of it i've made probably a
thousand videos at this point get
anywhere from a sketch to a one-minute
thing
and that's how i got the the
my first movie role i've been acting for
17 years wow and uh so it i i hate to
say there's no real
way to go right now but uh they're
certainly not looking for talent
nope
just um
but checking out boxes i guess they know
when they see it they do yeah that's why
you put yourself out there yeah yeah
yeah i had to give up the dream i
actually had to kill the dream because i
started to get
booked on tv shows and bigger and bigger
roles and i thought oh now i'm going to
make a living and then it just came to a
screeching halt
and it was the woke ideology and they
weren't hiding it and so i said i have
to kill the dream do it myself and
that's it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you